yeah um so yeah that guy definitely LIF
the slam there he sure
did another L Soul Man another another
gain Soul pretty soon I don't know about
that one still man oh all of y'all that
are stuck in this dark cloud of Islam
are lost and God is calling you guys out
one Soul at a time that's right now we
we have the truth man
alhamdulillah yeah voice sounds familiar
man who are
you um my voice sounds familiar yeah
have we talked before oh yeah yeah we
did yeah yeah a while ago yeah we talked
a while ago yeah are you
Hassan no
no Malik Malik Malik yeah I think I
remember you Malik Your Voice Sounds Tik
Tok Tik Tok on Tik Tok Malik from Tik
Tok okay no worries so memory you got
good memory that's good man I can
remember voices and stuff I can remember
you know I got a good ear you know
sometimes I do music you know what I'm
saying so I gotta hear stuff you
know so tell me man you feel me tell me
man tell me we uh I'm claiming that you
guys need our Bible man you guys need
our Bible you can't stand if you do not
have our Bible what do you think of that
um I would I would say is um to be
honest um I'm not even being rude to you
or anything is is kind of hypocritical
from you from like from your perspective
like saying that saying that the Quran
needs the Bible because how you say I'm
I'm keeping it respectful Logic on on no
I'm okay okay okay but it's kind I don't
know I know it's hurt but you kind of
use the Quran to confirm your Bible
don't you need confirm your Bible no no
okay what confirms the Bible logic if if
you like to this is what I do man let me
tell you let me come on man come on man
I'm about to give you the code right now
all
right come on man
man come on okay how do you know that
the the like you use the back as in the
Quran you use the Quran as well look how
do you know that the word of Allah the
word of God is is Jesus how do you
confirm let me tell you what I do use
the use the Quran bro can you hear me
can you hear me hello yeah I can hear
you I hear you yeah yeah act like he
can't hear you okay let me tell you what
I do I do not use the Quran to confirm
the Bible I do not believe in the Quran
the Quran in totality is a false book in
my from my position however that's
that's good okay okay however since I am
engaging with Muslims
and the Quran is your Authority I'm
showing you that the positions that you
guys have go against what your Quran
says that's all I'm showing you so if
you say oh Avery your Bible's corrupted
I'mma Be Like You can say that but your
Quran doesn't say that oh Avery you know
I'm be like uh that's not what the Quran
says you know so that's that's all so
okay okay I understand you're coming
from that angle okay okay not bad not
bad you just you know that's very smooth
there okay um me you me yeah I feel you
okay so would it be fair to say that um
I don't need your Bible you don't need
my Quran would it would that be fair
would be fair are you still on the topic
that the Quran needs the Bible no well
not not just the Quran but you as a
Muslim you need the B you need the Bible
so I wouldn't say I need the Bible it's
so let me let me let me tell you this
why because even in the Quran it's it it
tells you that you need the Bible like
it tells Muhammad that he needs the
bible really I don't think I don't think
there's ever a verse that says you need
the Bible chapter 10 verse 94 I know
chapter 10 chapter 10 verse 94 so if you
want to know the context uh the verses
before it is speaking about um the the
children I believe is the children of
Israel um uh being saved from Pharaoh
you know them crossing the you know uh
you know Moses you know hitting a stick
and you know all of that stuff those
stories so it says on that context if
you are in doubt of these stories and it
doesn't I know I know the it doesn't say
the prophet like literally is in
Brackets um you know the the translators
think is the prophet I don't I don't
personally think is literally the
prophet but it's I think it's speaking
to the um you know his people because
the you know there's a lot of verses
about you know the pagans they used to
say oh yeah uh they were surprised about
you know men being prophets and you know
Allah says go ask them about the you
know if were Propet say it's mammad all
the comment I know I know I know they
say it but they can be wrong about it
you know all of them they're humans no
they're humans they okay say for example
it is the prophet now if you are in
doubt about these stories what we have
revealed to you that these stories about
what we revealed to you no no it it
doesn't say these stories it says yeah
but what's what's the context let me say
the verse it says if you are in doubt
about what we have revealed to you not
these stories it just says in general if
you are in doubt about what we have
revealed to you go and ask those who
have been reading the scriptures before
you I know listen logic you're you're a
good guy man I know you understand
you're very clever before the verses
what what was it talking about can you
tell me please can you give me the
context what we was talking about it's
going over some things of that happened
in the previous scriptures yeah thank
you very much so it's talking about the
just literally two verses before it and
three verses before it is talking about
the children of Israel being saved by
Allah correct so what so what is
Muhammad supposed to do if he's doubting
what Allah's telling him where is he
supposed to go so it says so it says if
you are in doubt about these stories
we've revealed to
you the Revelation man yeah but that's
the context bro
you're taking it out of you're taking it
out of context so what is he doubting
about then what what what is Allah
saying if you are in doubt about what
can you tell me the Revelation that has
been re if you're in doubt about the
Revel about the Revelation or what has
been revealed to you yeah it says what
has been revealed to you yeah so but in
what context like what's he talking
about Allah is talking about the
children of Israel being correct let's
let's go with because I don't want us to
get stuck here let's go with your point
of view that it's it's talking about
specifically certain stories um about
Israel fine how does he go and verify
that what Allah is telling him is true
according to that that verse so it says
if you are in doubt about you know the
the stories of that we reveal to you so
he you can go ask uh the the you know
the people that have been G the
scripture which are the Christians and
the Jews at the time that you know that
they can confirm to you that you know
the children of Israel were saved and uh
and you know saved by Allah how do they
confirm it with him how confir it how do
they confirm it to
him how do how do they confirm they'll
be like yeah that's true but the thing
is now hold on no how they can't just
say it how do they confirm it how so you
they would confirm it when you go up to
them and ask them has has the children
of Israel been saved by Allah like have
they've been saved like you know the
story of Moses they're going to confirm
that because where do they get that from
though yeah in the in their scriptures
that they had of course of course of
course they had the stories of uh
Pharaoh you know oppressing the Jews in
order so here's the point in order to
verify Muhammad's prophethood no no no
no yes it is because it tells him don't
be a doubter if he's in doubt about what
he's receiving the Revelation he's
getting about these sto let's say about
what what what is what does it mean to
have something revealed the context okay
I just said it to you the context what
does it mean to have something revealed
is is is being revealed
Revelation revealed okay Revelation okay
go all right good so when if Muhammad is
in doubt about the revelations he's
getting from Allah about these previous
stories he's supposed to go to the
people who have these
stories who believe in the stories yeah
the the the believe in the story of
Moses they have the stories that's
that's why they can confirm it for him
because they have the stories okay so
Muhammad if he was in doubt needed the
Bible that's the point to clarify his
Revelations I don't okay let me just put
this in like I'm going to make it like
uh very easy for you to understand so it
you already read it like it about the
stories okay now the problem is if if
Allah says if you are in doubt now
that's there's a if right there and now
you're going to have to provide the
evidence that he was in doubt and he
went to them and you know asked them
like you know what I mean no I don't
because I don't believe I'm not going
off bro I'm not going off and I can show
you this actually I can show you that he
was ready to throw himself off off the
cliff because he was doubting that he
was a prophet and Gabriel had to
reminding him
is not that I know
in they heard is they heard there's no
that's what was happening there's no
eyewitness that shows that he was about
to sahkari
but I know if you want you want to
reject your sources you can reject your
sources you're not hearing me you're not
hearing me the Hadith says they heard
that the prophet was going to throw
himself off a cliff they heard word no
worries you know what that means no
worries I got you man that's not even my
point we can go through the argue we can
argue little things not my point here my
point is is that according to your
authentic sources Muhammad was doubting
his Revelation and was ready to throw
himself off the cliff that's what your
authentic sources say you want to throw
it away fine no worries no no listen
hold on hold on hold on no here's I know
you just said something I just I know
I'm gonna continue to
finish
yeah the point is is that the Quran says
if Muhammad's in doubt it tells him what
to do in case he's in doubt it tells him
exactly what to do so there's an if
there there's an if
okay if Muhammad is in doubt what does
he need to verify or clear his doubts
what does Allah tell him he need if if
yeah if he if he is in doubt if Muhammad
is in doubt you they can he can go ask
them about uh the story of uh Moses you
know being he needs the Bible to clarify
his doubts correct no not read the Bible
go ask the people of who have the Bible
because they have the that would clarify
his doubts correct don't be dishonest
here bro I don't have time I I don't
know what type of Bible no listen logic
I don't know what type of Bible they had
okay they had scriptures who cares what
type of Bible they have
bro stop arguing like like I don't know
why you guys do this just be honest with
your text according to your text
Muhammad needed the Bible to clarify his
doubts correct if he had any doubts
about what then it doesn't matter that's
not the point that's not the
point it doesn't matter if he had doubts
what did Allah tell him he needed to
clarify his doubts to to go ask the
people of the scripture the clever the
scholars you know people people who had
the Bible to clarify his doubts right
who had the
scriptures thank you so he needed the
Bible to clarify his doubts correct to
to to ask the people of the scriptures
if he had doubt yes so he needed the
Bible to clarify his doubts
correct not the Bible the scriptures the
scriptures are the Bible I don't believe
in your Bible the Bible is doesn't
matter what you believe you could
believe in a purple donkey with five
Wings what I'm saying to you is that we
have the manuscripts that predate muham
by hundreds of years that I can show you
Hebrew manuscripts Greek manuscripts
that that debunk everything that you're
saying we have the evidence they're
carbon data we have the sources we have
the quotations from the church fathers
what the text said we have the
translation of the New Testament into
syak around the year 400 we have the
Latin translate we have all of these
translations let me tell you how much
manuscript evidence we have right almost
6,000 manuscripts of the New Testament
that date up to hundreds of years before
Muhammad many of them if all those
manuscripts were destroyed destroyed God
forbid we can reconstruct most of the
New Testament just from the quotations
of the church fathers that were in the
first couple of hundred years 300 years
not just that we have the Dead Sea
Scrolls that predates the life of Jesus
by a couple of hundred years we also
have the Greek translation of the Old
Testament that goes 200 years before the
time of Jesus we also have the Aramaic
translations in the first centuries that
existed we have the old Greek
translation that tell us what the
scriptures were what was the Hebrew
Bible and what was the new test
we don't need we don't need to We There
the the claim that we don't have the
same Bible stands on absolutely nothing
not inside the sources of the Quran not
inside the sources of the Hadith and
even from historical evidence we can
prove that the Bible that we have today
is the same Bible that existed in the
time of Jesus the Same Old Testament and
what his disciples wrote we still have
from manuscripts okay okay so can you
prove to me that what um you know was
having or you know the Christian and the
Jews at that time were the Old Testament
that you have today you know you I'm
guessing you guys are Protestant so if
they have if they had the Protestant
Bible can you show me any proof that
that's not that's hold on for a second
the Quran is saying to go to what hold
on for a second to go what the
Christians and the Jews had in the time
of Muhammad we have historical sources
that tell us what the document is we
have evidence that predates it of what
the manuscripts are we had the Alo codex
and and Co the Leningrad codex that goes
to the medieval period that is most of
the Hebrew Bible that was the oldest one
that we have when we found the Dead Sea
Scrolls in 1948 in Israel there were
seven caves a Jewish guy went in there
knocked it down we found all of these
ancient Hebrew manuscripts that predate
the life of the Messiah that line up
with the Bible that we have
now
okay okay and and I can respect that um
I mean that's you have to respect that
you're not doing us any favors this is
the evidence of History if you negate
this then you're going against history
literally um I would say your Bible is
unreliable anyways so really yeah I mean
do you know who the authors of the Old
Testament are and the New Testament wait
wait wait you literally didn't hear
anything I just said if that's your
answer this this
is this for them radar that is a it's
it's you you just got to show them that
what they're saying is dumb as heck
that's what
you he just he just said can you show me
who wrote the New Testament like or let
me let me just ask you this um let me
ask you this I know that hurts logic
like you me to ask you about you know
who wrote
the I got you you believe in the Torah
right I believe that there was a Torah
that was revealed by Allah to uh to
Moses yeah who wrote it else wrote who
wrote it yeah uh probably Moses yeah
most likely wait what most likely so you
don't
know I mean the qur I don't the Quran
doesn't specifically say that
Moses so it sounds like the Torah has an
anonymous author according to your view
I mean I don't believe your Old
Testament is is the Torah I don't care
you believe in a Torah you don't know
who wrot I believe let me clarify what I
said I believe in the Torah the law that
was given to Moses how do you know that
the Torah was given to Moses the Quran
States it
show me where the Quran says the Torah
was given to Moses uh five I think it's
5442 542
nope bro it stes it wait give give me a
minute gonna show you just going to show
you how dumb your position is no the
Quran States it yeah okay you want me to
yeah I want you to give me the verse
give me the verse where it says the
Torah was given to Moses radar get your
popcorn everybody get your snacks going
to be a minute all right we
wait he's going to bring us verses that
say mo given a book that the people was
given a scripture he's going to give us
these type of verses but none of them
clarify what those scriptures or books
are he's not going to say the Torah was
given to him but we'll see I'm not a
prophet but let's see if my prophecy is
correct
[Music]
shoot
D that's some worship
scatting
that's
[Music]
right that's what I
hear any day now
Mal shoot up D
Hunter miss you
Hunter he just text me that's funny
shoot up let me get another bag of chips
because this is crazy
yeah come on bro you got it you got
it we're waiting for
you
yeah um so clarify what were you saying
so show me what show me a
verse
uhhuh as in that the Torah um was
revealed by Allah no show the verse that
the Torah was given to
Moses show of that I mean five
wait hold
on oh you're going to learn to stop
challenging me man you know I'm a
shake I know you like to call yourself
that man um but it was it says
it I mean who was it given to According
to Islamic tradition can you tell me
according to Islam I know you're trying
to look for it specifically but
According to Islamic tradition that's B
tradition and Christian
tradition the T was
Moses no what do bro I I just said to
you what do Muslims say that the Torah
was given to Moses right that's what
they say that my question yeah no that's
what yeah that's what Muslims believe
right that's what our belief is right
yeah I don't care about your belief
prove it to me exactly so I know you're
trying to look for a verse that
specifically says what you you just said
like show me the Quran where it says
Moses was given the the Torah you know
but in the Quran it says that him and
his brother was given the scriptures
yeah what
scriptures there's a verse that says
they were given um scriptures bro
yeah so what is it know it doesn't say
it doesn't say
that the Quran
says we have sent down the Torah to who
and who was it sent out yeah to to Moses
bro yeah show me the verse that says it
was sent down to Moses I know you want
you want to look for it specifically but
you know what I mean like I I don't I
don't really I don't know where it helps
your case really it shows that you don't
I'm showing you what I believe you're
you're stealing from us while at the
same time rejecting our material and our
on come on I I know you I know you say
the Quran play right the Bible while
saying the Bible is and unreliable oh
yeah yeah we stole from the Bible yeah I
know we don't have the mistakes that you
have as well man that's very
so show me where your don't have that
you have according to the Quran Pharaoh
was in the time of Moses and and and uh
there was kings in the time of Joseph
don't you think that if we copied we
copied your mistakes your Bible is full
of contradictions and mistakes we don't
have
inconsist again the Quran says Allah
revealed
the there you go can you take a guess
who he revealed to who to Moses show me
the verse you show me a verse where it
shows you told me a Bible verse where it
says it was it was revealed to
Moses come on specifically the way you
see it you want come on bro stop being
like
AIC nice try nice try man nice
try nice try nice try man but anyways is
that your whole argument today of Moses
you know G being given the scripture the
point this is the point let me let me
try to explain it maybe I could
translate for a little bit the premise
of the show is that Muslims need the New
Testament essentially the whole Bible in
order to make sense of their text okay
okay your text is incomplete the Quran
claims to be a detailed explanation of
all things it says that the but the
you're claiming that the Torah was given
to Moses but you can't find that Ayah
inside the Quran that's the problem no
no he wants it specifically like I can I
can I know like I know I know you guys
are can you find it can you find it can
you find it
hold on I know can you find it yes or no
can you find it can I speak but can you
find it can you answer the question I
you want it verb for 20 minutes we've
been waiting for you to find the
conversation Avery's being really nice
can find it listen can I can I speak so
for ver
verbatimly it doesn't say like
specifically like straight away so it's
not a detailed explanation so it's not a
detailed explanation right there you go
which makes your argumentation sound
like this so
I I know you got nice nice nice things
over there listen the Quran is detailed
in in the way Allah wants you the way
you oh so so it's not detailed in the
way the word means detailed it's
detailed the way Allah means it and
changes things right changes the meaning
of word on the Quran is not changed like
your Bible can I speak the Quran is not
changed and corrupted like your Bible
but I can I can say I
can
yeah